. Today, we're going to be speaking with Mark
Tushnet, who is emeritus professor at Harvard
Law School and also a specialist in U.S. and
comparative constitutional law.
So great to have you on.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
So I guess to get into this conversation,
there's been significant debate over the last
few months since the passing of Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg about the correct
number of Supreme Court justices and questions
like whether there should, for example, be
a term limits for Supreme Court justices.
But there's another approach, and that's one
of questioning whether we really even need
or should have a Supreme Court.
So, I mean, let's let's just start there.
What do you believe the purpose of the Supreme
Court was originally?
And does it still fulfill that purpose?
Well, the basic idea of the court was that
you needed somebody that would be able to
enforce the provisions of the Constitution,
you could expect politicians to debate the
constitutional issues and reach compromises
and so on.
And so politics might be one way of making
sure that people adhere to the Constitution.
But early on, people started worrying that
politicians might find it in their mutual
interest to do something that was inconsistent
with the Constitution, to agree on some program
that gave the president too much power.
Sure.
Or more likely, that we have what we think
of today, enact programs that violated individual
rights.
And the thought was you could insert a court
into the process so as to to check against
those possibilities.
And at this point in time, is that number
one still necessary?
And number two is that the primary activity
that the Supreme Court is engaged in checking
that.
Well, the second question.
No, actually, it turns out not the primary
thing the court does, things that don't get
as much attention is interpret statutes, tell
Congress, passes a statute and it's got some
provisions in it that aren't clear.
And the Supreme Court comes up with an authoritative
interpretation of the statute on the first.
I think it's it's a tricky question about
whether the court is now either meeting or
doing too much in terms of enforcing constitutional
provisions.
The reason it's tricky is that we now understand
that there's a lot of that would put it this
way, reasonable disagreement about what the
Constitution actually means.
And if everybody thinks they know the Constitution
prohibits things that they don't like happening.
But it turns out that it's very difficult
to say that very often legislatures or the
president actually do things that nobody could
fairly say are consistent with the Constitution.
Occasionally they did once in a while.
But most of the time what the court is doing
is saying you have this interpretation of
the Constitution.
Maybe it's a reasonable one, but we have a
different one.
And we're going to stop you from doing what
you think is consistent with the Constitution.
So in terms of.
Yeah, so in terms in terms of if there were
no Supreme Court, is it is it as simple as
the the next lowest court's decision?
It becomes the final decision.
Is it that simple or is there more rearranging
that would need to be done?
Well, you'd probably want to do more rearranging.
I mean, what if it were if you just took the
court out of the process entirely, then you'd
end up with the possibility of a court in
California saying something constitutionally,
OK?
And a court in Massachusetts saying it's not
OK.
Yeah, that's not impossible.
I mean, you can live with a world like that,
but it's sort of awkward.
We think it's our Constitution.
So you probably if you take the court out
of the process, you probably want to take
the lower courts out of it as well.
And how would you do that?
Would you establish some kind of a.
Well, I mean, I won't I won't even pretend
to know how how you would do it, how how would
it be done?
What would what would be the way that you
would rearrange that process?
Well, my preferred solution would be to say,
yes, we can still keep the courts involved
for reasons I'll get to in just a moment.
But they should apply a standard that we could
even write it into the Constitution, that
they should hold things unconstitutional only
if they are my phrase is manifestly unreasonable.
And that sharply reduces the degree to which
the courts, any court could could intervene
in constitutional interpretation, would still
give them some role, but only for extreme
cases in terms of the more common reforms
that are sometimes mentioned or changes to
the court, things like changes to the process
by which by the mere chance or timing of who
is president at the time that a vacancy is
created, changing that.
So it's not just the whim of whether there's
a Republican or a Democrat in the White House
changing the number of justices on the court,
putting term limits for being on the court.
Do you like any of these?
All of them?
None of them.
So I'm in favor of any program that's likely
to have some effect on reducing the role of
the court in our political life.
OK, people, the most popular thing is the
things you've mentioned are term limits.
And I'm.
I've signed on to a term limits proposal,
people who favor them to think that if you
have sort of a regular process of arrival
and departure, then the stakes for each appointment
will go down and that might lower the willingness
of the court to get involved in deep political
matters.
The appointment process would be more routine,
less highly politicized.
I think that might happen.
The expanding the size of the court, which
is also something I currently favor, would
temporarily actually make the court more prominent
because people would focus on on.
Well, they've just.
Expanded the court to change the rulings that
are coming out of it, but people also seem
to think that eventually there will be some
sort of equilibrium where first Democrats
expand the court and Republicans expand the
court.
And eventually people come to understand that
that's not a terrible, terribly great way
of doing things.
And what you really want to do is, again,
lower the temperature of the court's activity
so that people talk about reducing the legitimacy
of the court.
I think that's basically a good thing.
And so if court expansion had that effect,
that would be OK with me, too.
When it comes to the idea of and I know that
this is sort of a different, different question,
the idea of constitutional originalism, which
is a very, very big debate to me.
There's a few elements that that sort of don't
pass the sniff test that are very often mentioned.
And I'm curious to get your thoughts on it.
One is, if we're talking about constitutional
originalism as thought at the time of the
Constitution's creation, when we talk about
bearing arms, we would have to account for
the types of arms that existed at the time
and recognize a lot of what's available today
would be out of scope, even even theoretically
imaginable at the time.
When you talk about cruel and unusual punishment,
what we have today is dramatically different
than what would have fallen under that definition
at the time.
So how what is your sense in terms of this
debate around originalism, which is often
put forward by those who seem unwilling to
concede some of these points on cruel and
unusual and on the Second Amendment that I've
brought up?
But I think we have to distinguish between
two kinds of originalism.
There's the originalism that academics have
come up with, OK?
And academics have a decent account of academic
originalists have have come up with a decent
account of the Second Amendment problems and
how we can deal with them and the cruel and
unusual punishment provision and a whole bunch
of other things.
Equality for women is a significant matter.
So the academic theory actually has a certain
amount of credibility.
But then there's the practice of originalism
by judges who say they are originalists.
And that's sharply different from what the
academics say.
And it's entirely inconsistent.
They are originalist when the results they
come up with fit, they're mostly conservative
ideology and then they depart from originalism
when they haven't figured out how to.
Defend their conservative positions in originalist
terms.
The best example of that, incidentally, is
affirmative action.
There's just no no credible should the academics
have a credible way of defending or attacking
affirmative action on originalist grounds.
But conservative judges haven't even bothered
to try.
They just think that it's inconsistent with
some fundamental principle of equality that
they're committed to without trying to link
that principle to original understandings.
OK, this is good because it adds a level of
nuance when we hear those who are not particularly
well-educated on this bring up this issue
of of original intent in order to defend some
of their conservative ideals.
So when we talk about constitutional originalism,
you're pointing out there is judicial constitutional
originalism and then there is academic constitutional
originalism and that these are two different
things.
And as you're putting forward the idea that
academic constitutional originalism does deal
with some of these apparent contradictions,
maybe we could dig into one of them, like,
for example, on 2nd Amendment and the idea
of what arms referred to hundreds of years
ago versus the weapons available today.
How would the academic originalists sort of
deal with that?
The academic account is actually there are
two versions of the academic account.
One is.
Tied to what we mostly think about these days,
and it is you say.
You have to think about the kinds of weapons
that people had in mind that were understood
to be covered by the Second Amendment right
and.
When they thought about and talked about the
weapons that were covered by the Second Amendment,
they referred to weapons that everybody has
access to or in the current phrase, weapons
in common use.
And so now you translate that to the current
circumstances and you ask what weapons are
used today.
So weapons and current use then were muskets
and things like that.
They're not in current use now, but ordinary
handguns are in use.
On the other hand, bazookas are not encouraged.
So you're making an analogy.
In other words, you have to you have to think
of what was what would be analogous to those
weapons today.
Yeah, OK, exactly.
So that's one way of doing it.
The other way is much more radical.
And actually, I think in my own view, is more
connected to what was actually going on.
The original understanding of the second view
of the Second Amendment was that it was a
way of ensuring that ordinary people would
be able to fight against an overreaching government.
They would be able to arm themselves to protect
themselves, not against criminals, but against
soldiers.
And given what the military has today, that
would imply a very, very high a standard for
what it would mean.
Exactly.
And no no contemporary defender of the Second
Amendment except people associated with these
Michigan militia types who want to go there.
And so the judges say, well, we don't you
know, they may have had this original understanding
about what was called the insurrectionist
view, but but that's not what we think the
original understanding was.
And they do that precisely for this sort of
instrumental reason and focused reasons.
They don't want to say people have a right
to have bazookas or anti-tank weapons.
Right now, it seems like you could apply a
similar standard to this idea of cruel and
unusual punishments.
Right.
Where where you would say, well, just because
there are things available now that weren't
available then and some of the things that
were done then have gone out of style, we
have to sort of evaluate what is analogous
at this time.
Right, right.
And and here, in fact, again, the academic
position is.
Yeah, that's right.
And it might be that in particular, capital
punishment or life in prison without parole
for juveniles.
Those might be inconsistent with the fundamental
ideas that were understood to be written into
the cruel and unusual punishment punishments
clause.
And again, what judicial originalists do is
they abandon the originalism and they say,
well, look, the text says capital crimes.
So whatever they thought, cruel and unusual
punishment meant, they also thought capital
punishment was constitutionally permissible.
And so, again, you see this inconsistency
between the practice of conservative judges
who want to uphold capital punishment and
originalism as it might be coherently worked
out.
Absolutely fascinating.
I think the big takeaway is, no matter what
you call your philosophy, there is still debate
to be had in figuring out exactly how we define
it and different versions of it.
That's right, I mean, I think the the again,
I'm an academic, the academic view of these
debates is that with relatively minor exceptions.
Whatever your theoretical position is, you're
going to be able to fit your current political
views into it, and that means that the theoretical
stuff really, really isn't doing any serious
work.
What's going on is you're a liberal or conservative
and that's how you rule.
Yes, very well described by by behavioral
economists.
In fact, like Daniel Kahneman and and others
who have talked a lot about that type of motivated
reasoning, which clearly exists within the
issue of constitutional scholarship as well.
We've been speaking with Mark Tushnet, emeritus
professor at Harvard Law School, a professor.
It's been such a pleasure speaking with you.
I so appreciate your time.
I enjoyed it and appreciate being on The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.